hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to the game engine series
yes we are back this is not abandoned um
i know it's been a very long time since
the last episode and i
apologize for that i've been super busy
with like working on hazel dev and other
kind of youtube videos but i didn't want
to totally forget about this series i
have been kind of thinking
about it at the in the back of my mind
and i think what we're going to do today
is something a little bit different than
we usually do so we agree that the
format kind of going forward
would be more or less me live streaming
myself working on this
and then kind of making that into a
video
but um today i think is going to be
pretty cool because what we're going to
do today is we're going to have a go at
implementing a content
browser panel and i'll show you what
that is in a minute but basically
this is something that i haven't uh
prepared this is
is not something that i've like live
streamed and i'm not going to just drag
the code in i'm actually going to take
you through my process of doing
something like this from start to finish
i don't know what it's going to turn out
kind of looking
like again as i mentioned i haven't
really done anything like this before
but hopefully it will kind of enlighten
um you know you guys and maybe show you
a little bit more of like the
thought process that goes into something
like that and how i would approach it
in almost like kind of an unedited
fashion i do
kind of think there will be some editing
going on because i'm sure that there'll
be cases in which i'm just going to
stare at it and
not know how to do something and i am
going there might be like minutes of me
just reading documentation or code which
i'm sure you don't want to see but
anyway we'll see how we go so first step
i want to i want to kind of uh you know
talk about where we left off so
we have um hazel here which of course is
committed on github
we have this scene pink cube and we can
load all of this stuff
so what do i want to do and where are we
taking this going forward so we have
this sprite renderer that's capable of
rendering a sprite of a given color
that's fine but i think the next big
step here
is to actually be able to render
textured sprites
so if we can render a texture on this
thing which we can
like now 2d renderer definitely supports
textures we just have no way of doing it
through like the editor
interface so if we could do that then
i think that we're pretty much at the
stage where we could make almost
any 2d game like we would need to script
it through c
plus plus we don't have like c sharp or
any other scripting language so
there is that kind of limitation and
then also
um you know some other kind of
components like
audio aren't really present but in terms
of actual gameplay
you know if we can make entities move
programmatically which we can
and if we can apply a texture to a quad
then
that's pretty much any 2d game you could
think of that's most of the work kind of
done
because it is kind of easy to do that a
lot of the other logic
lies in the actual programming not
necessarily like the features that the
editor what the renderer has to provide
which is pretty cool so that's kind of
my my line of thinking here
you know we're kind of moving towards
being able to complete like a 2d game
that's like the goal
and these are kind of the steps to get
us there so
in order to actually render textures we
have a few options i mean i could have
gone the easy route
which now that i think back i'm not sure
why i didn't but
ultimately um what i could do is just
add a little like texture
field over here in this bright renderer
with it with like a little open button
you could click it it could open like
you know a kind of open file dialog like
this
and then you could just navigate to like
assets textures and load something
right but instead of doing that what i
thought would um
what i thought would be cooler and a
little bit more kind of
uh along the lines of what we would
expect from this engine in the future
is if we actually had like down here
like a content browser panel that would
let us kind of navigate
our project and just drag a texture that
we could maybe even preview a thumbnail
of
right into that slot right so we would
click here and we would drag it into
this slot and suddenly we would be
rendering
that texture instead of this color or
maybe in addition to this color so the
color would tint the texture
and we would set it to white if we
wanted to like not tint it or something
so that's basically the
kind of outline of why we're doing this
now what is a content browser panel that
is a great question let's go ahead and
launch hazeldev
which by the way you guys can get access
to if you go to patreon.com and help
support
everything that i'm doing here on
youtube as well as hazel's development
then you will basically get access to
this um which is uh hazel dev
um and i'm right in the middle of i'm
playing around with like a little
blue bloom implementation which at the
moment is uh not going too well but
anyway inside hazeldev we have this
content browser panel
now i didn't make this this was made by
peter
who is listed over here as part of the
hazel core team by the way so huge thank
you to him for making this
but basically what this is is this
content browser panel we can search here
you know we can navigate through the
entire repository we can go to like um
well in the
i guess in the uh um spirit of textures
let's go to like i don't even know if we
have like proper textures here we have
meshes
um and then maybe we have like uh sauce
you know
we have like some textures here right
these are some textures we could
essentially and i think we can even
um click on this and like take this
albedo and drag it in here
while that works that's nice i haven't
actually tested that in a while so it's
nice that it works
but anyway you get the point so i kind
of want this functionality
for us to be able to kind of navigate
our repository and then just drag this
like into a
into an actual texture slot as opposed
to
having to like open a file from disk
so how do we achieve something like that
well
uh that's a good question let's begin
so the first thing i want to do is think
about where this belongs
now a content browser panel is
definitely not something we would
probably ever have in the runtime
there are a lot of cases for having
these content kind of panels
in the actual run time so meaning i
would want to put it into hazel not
hazelnut uh like for example like a
scene hierarchy panel
why would you ever want that in hazel's
runtime
this is actually a question that gets
asked pretty often like in the patreon
chat or in like
i get like messages about it every now
and then the reason
is um and hazeldev does this quite a lot
with a lot of its panels actually
is because just because something can be
used in the editor
and seems like it only should be used in
the editor doesn't mean it's not a
useful tool to have
for debugging so in other words like
pretend that you are
trying to debug your scene on like an
android phone
right not that hazel supports android
but if it did you know you're on your
android
phone and you just want to like debug
you know why is my entity not there
well like where is it is it even in the
scene right so you bring up the scene
hierarchy panel right there on your
phone which you can obviously do because
it's all i'm gooey it's not written in
like
qt or wpf or something like that it's a
lime gui so it's all just c
plus rendering right um you can bring it
up and you can be like oh
okay it is in my scene and then you can
click on it and see that it's transform
is like
way off so something went wrong with the
transform i think you're going to get
you kind of get the point so basically
it's kind of these those panels aren't
really useful for like
a shipping game but it is still useful
for debugging and like maybe qa testing
and all that stuff so
whenever i kind of make tools for the
editor i always
think about whether or not it's actually
something that we want to have
for the runtime and i think that in this
case it definitely
is or rather definitely is not a content
browser panel is something that displays
a folder that we have on our computer
with assets that we may or may not want
to use right we're not trying to make an
editor for like our phones in terms of
debugging i don't really need the
ability to drag in certain assets that
the engine might not even be using
that's a bit weird
so it's clearly something that we would
much rather have just for
the editor so in that case it should
work with
just the editor so we haven't seen a
hierarchy panel that's actually a good
point
so in hazelnut i'm sorry in hazeldev
this is not part of
the hazelnut thing it's actually part of
hazel
and that's kind of why so at the moment
we've um we've made it part of
uh hazelnut which is okay but i kind of
i did give my reasons as to why we might
not want that
okay so content
browser panel
it's kind of nice it feels like one of
those old school episodes where we
actually write all the code live
which is fun so we'll include our little
pre-compiled header and we'll include
content
browser panel and let's take a look
at what we want to have here
so um i don't know if we follow any kind
of like
pattern with our panels not really i
mean what we kind of want
is usually some kind of context now in
the future we'll have projects
and like a project will contain like an
assets directory and then
we'll that's basically the directory
that we'll be browsing at the moment we
just have this assets folder relative to
our current working directory so we'll
kind of
assume that that's what we want but in
the future we'll probably take in an
actual project into the constructor
other than that and that will kind of be
the context um other than that we
basically just have online gui render i
guess and then just like a default
constructor and that's probably it so
content browser
panel uh let's see
so we'll have that on i'm going render
we'll have
uh just a default constructor
and i'm sure we'll need like some
private variables and some other stuff
as well okay
so let's try and create this
um okay so on i'm glue render what is
that gonna do so again
um let's go to like see in hierarchy
panel and just see like what the basic
idea is for like creating panels and
stuff so we begin
um and this is really just the same time
it's not that i don't know how to do
this
uh it's not that it's complicated it's
just that
if you can copy and paste code from
somewhere it's usually a good
good way to go um you know if it depends
where from
and stuff depends what the code is but
it's usually okay all right so here we
draw obviously
um every kind of entity node so what do
we want to do here well for the content
browser panel
um the first step really is we kind of
want to and don't forget by the way that
is obviously an immediate mode gui
basically means that like you know we do
expect to run through this code
like every kind of frame so you have to
be a little bit sensitive to like
performance considerations as well
now i don't think this is a big deal um
but what we could do
uh is basically just list all the files
in the assets directory
so what i'll do at the moment is i'll
just say const expression like
stds string and we'll call this
our kind of assets directory
and i'll set it equal to assets now i
will say here
um now do we not have a constant
string can string not be a constant
expression
i guess not well it's not a big deal i
guess
but that's a bit annoying anyway um so
we'll say that this is uh
to be to be changed so once we have
um projects change
this so for now it's kind of just
hardcoded to be assessed but in the
future we will change this
okay so content browser um and then what
we'll do is we'll actually use
the file system that we have in sql
17 because the file system has
something called a directory iterator
and this iterator means that
we can basically just iterate through a
directory which i have no idea how to do
so let's just go ahead and google
this and we will see how we can use this
okay so we have this example here from
cdp reference
um we can basically iterate through
oh so we just have like a fastest and
referee iterator and then we get p which
is a path so let's go ahead and try
something like this basically
right so i'll go ahead and um
this will be a for loop auto p directory
system uh
for sorry file system uh directory
iterator and then we'll have
our assets directory
and then we can get the path here we can
get like the parent path if we want like
the directory or whatever
and i'm not like as far as like uh
recursive direction directories go and
stuff i think we'll probably have to
deal with that in a slightly different
way which we will do in a minute
okay so what's next so
let's go ahead and since we are inside
and i'm gooey kind of contact let's go
ahead and just render this as text right
so i'll say we'll do like percentage s
um and then we will just put basically p
uh what is p first of all p is a
directory entry path is the path and
then we can just do
dot string i don't want to do dot c
string or anything because i don't know
what the lifetime of that object will be
probably not and that is a const
reference actually so i'm sure it'll be
fine
we'll just have it as a string i guess
um
so that'll be our string
and then we'll put in path so it's
pretty exciting to have something like
this
because uh before sql 17 you basically
have to use like the win32 api or
like whatever your kind of um windows i
guess
uh sorry not windows operating system
api was so it's nice to have something
like this for sure
okay contents content browser panel
just duplicate this content browser
panel
content browser panel i'm gonna have
dreams about this content browser panel
so let's go up here
why don't we create this oh it's it's
just a uh it doesn't really need to be
created does it
it's just a stack allocated thing so
we just need to call on i'm going render
basically so where do we do that
for the scene hierarchy panel probably
in this function
yep now it's a good thing in the future
to just
start maybe adding adding these to a
list so you don't have to literally have
like every panel here
and by this i mean like some kind of
vector but let's take a look at this so
we should be already kind of at the
point where we should
see um every single uh i guess directory
or path really
that exists so this is kind of exciting
it's like the beginning
of our content browser panel let's just
dock it maybe down here
it's a nice spot for it so we have
assets uh cash assets fonts
assets scenes assets shaders assets
textures so you can see first of all
that um there's a few things here so we
have backslashes
we also have uh so texture shader scenes
fonts cache
so this is everything and it's also
relative to the working directory it
seems because it includes
assets itself so that's what we have in
here now
because we're doing this every frame at
the moment uh the cool thing is
is that if i like add a file here
cherno.txt you can see it's literally
here right so in like
two seconds we've like already created
something that can just
you know be almost used as a content
browser
people say c plus plus is slow to work
with um
so let's delete that it disappears great
so
all we want to do now is probably trim
that kind of working directory situation
um and also make a recursive function
out of this but the thing is we don't
really need to have it be a recursive
function all we need to do is enable us
to actually browse two parts
so what i want to do is as a very simple
case i'm going to change this to be a
button
instead and we're going to say that
basically what this is going to be
is if we if we click on that button
i want to try and navigate to that
directory now it's very important to
also distinguish between what is a
directory and what is a file
because um if it's a uh
if it's not a directory then like what
are you doing right so
if it is a directory let's go ahead and
add this kind of functionality to it
so i'll add a button um i guess will it
be a button yeah we might make it a
button either way
we'll see um i'll have path here maybe
but basically if it is a directory um
we'll render the button and then if the
button is pressed
um then we want to actually navigate
into that directory so how do we do that
well we have to keep track of some kind
of path that we're currently on
so i'm going to go ahead and i'll just
treat this as like a file system path
by the way this is a definitely
something worth noting if you're
unfamiliar with this file system thing
that uh exists in like sequels plus 17
uh like this this this came up in the
hazel core team
and i think that it's something that's
definitely worth mentioning
uh it's really quite important to
understand what classes actually are
right classes are obviously containers
of like
data of certain like variables
ultimately
and that's what kind of makes up a
certain class it's i think it's
important to understand
what a class is right so in the case of
this kind of
path class and there's a lot of stuff
here so i'm just trying to kind of
make this a little bit easier so we can
at least see
what this is so like line 14 29 is
roughly where it ends
you can see that basically the only
thing that is inside this path class
at least the msvc kind of you know
visual studio implementation
is string type text now what is string
type string type in this case is a wide
string
now a wide string is a wide char
right um so not like a utf-8 thing but
like a 16-bit kind of character
now um that being said
uh that's all a path is it's not some
magical file that contains like
some crazy file system link or like open
handle
to like you know a folder on your
computer or something weird
it's just a string it's it's a wide
string right
so uh don't be like too afraid of like
you know if you have to toss up between
like i'd rather store it as a string
because that's probably more efficient
than a file system handle
it's not a file system handle um it's an
actual
uh it's just a it is a string so it's
kind of you know
let this kind of be just hopefully
something that you guys can think about
in the future
not when it comes to maybe this
specifically but just in general just be
aware of the data that you're actually
manipulating
because it's easy with kind of higher
level languages to just forget
you know what is happening underneath
all of that abstraction
that kind of uh uh you know that makes
up all of your code basically
so i'll say current directory um and
that will be
that will be uh what we're currently on
so again uh you know on upon
construction
um so i'm actually going to create a
little constructor here we're going to
actually set this
to be the assets directory uh so
let me just take this away
so we're going to just set this to be
the assets directory and i guess we
could
do it up here
so what happens is when i actually
navigate to a directory
what i want to do is kind of simple so
first of all it's important to
like notice that um when we actually
printed this out it was pretty clear to
us that it was like assets
backslash whatever right so because it's
that
we don't really care too much about
the um whole asset slash thing
because everything is going to be
relative to assets now if we
really wanted to deal with that we could
just use there's like a relative
function inside the file system api
that's actually quite useful
but instead instead of what we can do
and what we need to think about is that
if we're currently in the assets
directory and we see something like
assets slash
you know what was here like shaders or
whatever we want to enter into that
directory
then we can't just take like assets or
our current directory which is assets
and try and append this to it
because if we do that then we wind up
with assets assets such
as shaders so what we really want is
because obviously we're just displaying
stuff that's in the current directory
we just want this last part um and
there's a few ways that we can do this
so i think if we just do p um
so okay once we actually have the path
right or p dot path
is the path kind of why does it keep
doing that
um then we have uh so stem
i think will might be stem it might be
like file name or something i don't know
to be honest but i'm pretty sure that
file name will actually give us the
um so let's maybe take a look at and
again you know this is
this is where some debugging is
kind of nice so let's just i don't know
why i've decided to
to do this let's let's not do that um we
might as well just i'm going here
right so let's just do path dot file
name
i'll do i am gui
text um and then this will be
p dot path dot file name dot string
i'm a little bit scared about using c
string because i
feel like um i feel like it won't
actually have that memory for us
so let's do p0
p1 so i want the file name and the stem
i just want to see what they are
because i have a feeling that
so this is the file name this is the
stem
so one thing i like to do quite often is
actually to validate like the data that
i'm
dealing with right so i don't i like to
be aware of what everything is
um yeah so see c and yeah okay so
uh this is what happens when we don't
it's because they're wide
characters so we have to actually do dot
string otherwise we just get like the
first character because
it runs into a null terminator an old
termination character really quickly so
cash cash
okay so in this case actually return the
same thing so what stem does
traditionally is it just returns the
name without the extension
so if i had something like that
churner.txt file or whatever
right shouno.txt you can see that in
this case the file name is turner.txt
but the stem is churno
so if you want to get the um the file
name without the extension
then uh that's what stem is but in this
case folders don't have extensions
um what if we had a folder with an
extension though i don't think would
that matter so like
you know dot test.text
see so the file name is test text the
stem is test
even though it's still a folder so that
just proves that we actually want to use
um well that makes sense obviously but
like we actually want to use file name
and not stem for this
because if we use stem then some folders
will be treated weirdly
so we're already checking to make sure
it's a directory so that's fine
so if we do this then all we really want
to do is current directory we do this
little divided by equals because that's
the operator that they've overloaded
um which is quite funny i think but it's
i guess it's kind of nice because it
looks like a path
um and then we put in
the file name right so
[Applause]
this is a string file name um
oh yeah we don't actually need to
convert it into a string we can just do
that
because we're appending a path we don't
need to waste time making it into a
string because it stores a wide string
natively
there is a bit of a conversion cost when
we go from a y string to a string
and also you generally want to probably
avoid using strings um we should be
using some kind of utf-8
um strings or something like that just
because at the moment i don't think this
will actually support
at least not in this way it probably
won't support like other languages so
like that's actually
worth testing because that's a common
problem people run into as well
so if i try to make a i'm just trying to
make a folder
but i'll call it something in russian so
like preview
um well we just got to crash so
good example of what not to do right um
and the reason that happened is because
we probably should have
used a wide string i don't even know if
i'm going properly supports y
wide strings or we should have done a
conversion i'm not sure why this crashed
though because
string should have actually tried to
convert it into a
char string like that anyway we'll
investigate other languages in the
future
but it was worth um it's just worth kind
of being aware it's not not that it's
worth being aware but it's
nice to be aware of certain things that
may crash your program
and dealing with strings properly is
definitely something that a lot of
people get wrong
all the time including myself obviously
so anyway
uh current directory um yeah so now
we're actually changing the current
directory
now at the moment again we're doing a
directory iterator over assets directory
we're going to change that now to be the
current directory
and by doing so i think we've just
created a bit of a
like a explorer kind of thing they can't
go back so this is our little
quest into creating windows explorer
we've got to delete that russian folder
and that's why russians are dangerous
because they can crash
everything all right so um
asset scenes uh i guess there's nothing
in there
let's quickly make a little back thing
so um it's worth not displaying a back
button past assets we don't really want
to give people access to the whole
computer through this thing
um probably at least so um we'll think
about that as well but
le as as we iterate through this um if
let's just do this so if the current
directory doesn't equal
um scd file system path
assets directory which i feel i should
have just made into a directory
um then uh we'll have a little back
button
which i will just call or maybe i'll
just do that which is our back button
and if it's pressed
then all i'm going to do is basically so
this if it's not the assets directory i
guess
um if it's not if it's or if it's empty
i guess it can't be empty right
because this will always be relative to
what like the working directory
we wanted to be relative to the assets
directory though i don't know it gets a
little bit
tricky i think here but basically we'll
we'll just do
um current directory equals current
directory.parent
path um and that's pretty much it i
don't know how
this will work if at all it will let's
just try
just because like we're not really
we're not really doing relative paths to
like assets or anything um yeah
okay so we don't have a backpack we
don't have a back button but now we do
so actually turns out it works perfectly
um
[Music]
so assets shaders assets scenes assets
fonts open
sans um let's maybe display files as
well
so we still want to display files it's
just that and let's just display them as
buttons so they don't look weird but we
we basically just won't make the button
do any we'll make the button not do
anything
so so path.c string i think is
reasonable
oh no no hang on that's not reasonable
at all actually none of this is
reasonable is it
because yeah because it's displaying
everything so let's let's kind of switch
up a bit so
what i will do is okay so the first step
um
into kind of formatting this so that it
looks a bit nicer
is we want to make sure that we're
relative to assets how do we do that so
there's something called um and where
shall we do this maybe like here
so std file system
relative um and then this will return a
path as relative
like to something else so um basically
what we'll do is we'll put the path in
first which is simply p dot path
and then the base path is actually what
we specify here
so the base path will be um
uh the assets directory basically so
hold up a second i just want to do this
um
okay this is probably just better to do
asset path um instead of this this clown
so maybe let's get rid of that
i guess i'll make a const um okay
so asset path we have here now and
that's that so now i can obviously just
type that in i don't have to go from the
string to path conversion anymore it's
just a path already
so yeah so i guess the moral of the
story as to what i was talking about
with this
and like be aware of what path is is
that now you don't really have to worry
about paths really
ever being strings right paths are
always capable of being
not just ascii right we just
demonstrated that by trying to make a
russian path and seeing it crash
um right so in other words keeping it a
string doesn't really make much sense
and if you want to keep it as a
wide string or a utf8 string or whatever
else
then it's uh it's the same essentially
as just keeping it as a path
so what's the downside of keeping it as
a path
nothing really the only real difference
between path and string
really is just the api that it gives you
the functions you can
call on the actual variable that's
really the only difference
so in other words now hopefully um
it'll be something that you kind of
think about when you make a path um it
feels like i'm
kind of talking down on you guys i'm not
what i'm doing i'm just kind of
i'm i'm almost frustrated at my own
experiences in the past
uh and that's kind of what's what's
coming through here so
let's set this to asset path okay
so um yeah so we have this we have this
great so relative to that
and that's kind of the path i want to
deal with so this is um
let's maybe call this it for like kind
of iterator so this is like
the actual in the actual kind of
variable that we're iterating through um
and there's a directory entry actually
i'll call it a directory entry
i think that's a bit better directory
entry
um and then this path what do we even
use this for so we'll use it for c
string here
and it's that's just going to be a
string um
sure i might just call it path string
though
and then this which i use a lot
i might just cost reference
path just to tidy this up a bit
okay so path path string
relative so um this is going to be
a auto relative path
and then this relative path is actually
what i kind of want to use
so let's do relative path string and
that will be this
and that is what we will use everywhere
so now we shouldn't have any of that
um uh
any of that kind of absolute well not
absolutely but relative to the working
directory path coming through
so we should only really have the name
so current directory let's see so
and what do we add to it just path file
name which is that original path file
name yeah it doesn't really matter
um let's go ahead and try and run that
okay so cache dot text fonts
scenes if we click on the file nothing
happens if we go into fonts
we get the back button we can see this
um
and here are all our files we can go
back we can't go back past this
textures okay so we actually still still
have texture slash blah blah
that's okay um i think it's just because
yeah so we've got the relative path
which i think is probably worth having
um but we obviously don't really want to
display the relative path string we want
to actually display display just like
the file name string
so how do we do that um
[Music]
i guess yeah i guess we don't need this
at all actually so file
string is going to be a
relativepath.filename.string
and that's actually what we'll use here
and actually while i'm here i think what
i might do
is i was going to use like a larger font
because it's kind of hard to see
but to be honest maybe for these videos
i'll just kind of try and leave the font
like larger because i think at the
moment what are we doing we're doing
like
um default is like 18
so like you know i should make like if
recording video
uh bigger but like let's just do like
font size
times two or something um just so that
maybe it'll be easier for you guys to
see it's almost hard for me to see
yeah there we go let me know if that's
better um
so yeah so here here are all of our
files fonts open sans
um shaders our shaders
and then obviously like textures and so
like the next step really is going to be
to kind of
take this texture um which at the moment
is showing up as this
it'd be nice to kind of display it like
as an icon obviously by the way i'm not
spending too much time at the moment at
least tweaking this and making it all
like a beautiful layout
i think that's kind of uh you know we're
just trying to make this functionally
work first
um because obviously like in terms of
like layout and stuff
um we uh yeah we we
definitely don't need to i think worry
too much about that and you can i'm sure
you guys could figure out a certain
layout and i'm going if you wanted to
and that's also something that you could
spend hours on uh and i'm definitely
guilty of that
another thing you could do by the way is
i'm not sure how taxing this is in terms
of performance to be completely honest
but you could obviously just like not do
this if you've done it once like if as
in if you've iterated through the
directory once
you can actually save every like
directory entry
into like some kind of list if you
wanted to and then simply
go through that list every frame to
render it but not actually hit the file
system every frame like this to get all
the information out from it
um or maybe you could just do it once
per second
and if you did it once per second that
way you could still pick up new files
right so i think that's kind of just
useful right because you'll see files
kind of
uh change and stuff because obviously at
the moment like if i'm inside like
fonts and i add a new font folder or
whatever
it's going to appear here instantly
which is kind of nice
right um because it's all kind of live
uh so that's definitely another idea but
i think next time what we'll do
is um let's just load up a scene
um next time what we'll do is we'll
actually try
and have and of course the font size
being so large kind of ruins everything
but what we'll try and do is add like a
little texture slot here
that we can actually go into like
textures and actually like try and like
say drag this cherno logo onto here
so that is the plan anyway hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button let
me know what you thought of this kind of
more
almost casual approach um i'm definitely
not saying that the series is going to
become this from now on
i probably will go back to like live
streaming this for more serious things
and kind of uh
you know working on it it's just that
because i have been so busy working on
some really exciting features
for hazel um and for like for hazel dev
uh
it's just honestly i'm just flat out at
the moment and just didn't have time to
actually probably sit down and
kind of uh you know plan this out and do
a series of live streams and then show
you the finished implementation
but i also thought that it would be it
might be beneficial and fun for you guys
to kind of watch how
i go about doing something like this
anyway thank you guys again for your
support you can support the series by
going to patreon.com and you'll get
access to hazeldev
um and all of that uh lovely uh kind of
other community stuff
and um yeah next time as i mentioned
we'll probably continue working on the
content browse and try and set up
textures because
the next kind of step there is also the
kind of the material workflow we want to
be able to
probably create materials and specify
maybe even custom shaders and stuff like
that
so that we can actually start kind of
building these 2d games anyway huge
thank you to all of you guys for
watching i'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you